vous avez votre chaîne youtube vous
passez plutôt monsieur mais vous vous
rendez compte qu'à un moment ça ne
décolle pas je répondrai question qui
m'a été posée par l'un d'entre vous sur
sa chaîne et sur le fait d'identifier
les points bloquants
et comment développer sa chaîne vous
allez voir ça tient à pas grand chose
il ya de plus en plus de chaînes qui
volent jour sur youtube et il est
extrêmement difficile d'y réussir
je partage avec vous mes meilleures
astuces toutes mes techniques pour
gagner plus de vue plus d'abonnés et
enfin réussir sur youtube parce qu'il
est voué à xian et activer la cloche
pour ne manquer aucune vidéo aujourd'hui
une vidéo questions réponses pour aider
alexis j'ai reçu un message d'alexis je
vous lis salue monsieur re je fais des
vidéo en stop motion avec des lego sous
forme d'interview humoristique il y à
une ambiance complètement décalé avec
des situations absurdes etc
je pense que je n'arrive pas à me faire
connaître car certains concepts un petit
peu trop ciblée et surtout je ne suis
pas régulier car le stop motion c'est
vraiment très long à faire donc je ne
suis pas trop présent sur youtube
si tu pouvais voir ma chaîne ce qui
serai sympa et que tu me donnes ton avis
continue comme ça que tu es super vidéo
merci beaucoup alexis j'ai été voir ta
chaîne j'étais déjà répondu aux
commentaires et je tenais vraiment à
partager ça avec tout le monde parce que
le problème que tu rencontres c'est un
problème que tout le monde rencontre il
ya souvent des petits points bloquants à
droite à gauche on a beaucoup de mal à
les identifier
pourtant une fois qu'on les a vus ça
paraît très clair et on peut ensuite
progresser et ensuite réussir sur
youtube
alors ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
regarder ensemble la chaîne d'alexis on
va l'analyser
on va voir ce qui marche ce qui ne
marche pas le contenu en tout cas
d'alexis moi je trouve super sympa c'est
du stop motion c du lego c'est super
drôle
il ya un vrai concept il ya vraiment de
l'humour derrière on sent qu alexis
c'est quelqu'un de drôle le truc est
bien écrit c'est très sympa après il ya
des points bloquants surtout des
questions de stratégie sur youtube et ça
on va pouvoir regarder ensemble et ce
qui pourra y d'alexis pourra
probablement vous aider vous aussi avant
de développer davantage je vais vous
poser la question du jour est ce que
vous voyez des points d'amélioration
sans votre chaîne qu'est ce qui bloque
qu'est ce qui fait que vous n'arrivez
pas à aller plus loin
quelles sont les choses selon vous à
mettre en place dès aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir progresser
si vous voyez tout ça vous le mettez en
commentaire et moi je vous répondrai
et puis je vais faire un détour sans vos
chaises la toute première chose à faire
quand on commence à vouloir comprendre
quel est le problème c'est d'aller voir
la concurrence voir ce qu'elle fait et
comment elle peut mieux réussir que vous
donc ce qu'on va faire
alexis fait du legos fait du stop motion
donc on va tout simplement taper légaux
stop motion ça me le propose et on voit
qu'on a d'autres suggestions après les
salles vers un peu plus tard ça vous
aidera pour votre référencement
lego stop motion qu'est-ce qui sort et
nous sort une première vidéo il ya un
mois avec 4 million deux cent mille vu
celle d'après il ya un nom un million
neuf cent mille vu celle d'après trois
semaines 6 millions 800 mille vue on
voit très très très clairement qu'il ya
un très gros volume de recherches sur
cette niche c'est quelque chose qui
marche plutôt pas mal et alors ce qui
est vraiment intéressant c'est quand on
va regarder la première vidéo qui fait 4
million deux cent mille vue vous cliquez
sur la chaîne et là vous voyez que cette
chaîne est là uniquement 72 mille
abonnés alors c'est pas uniquement c'est
déjà beaucoup mais ce qu'on voit très
bien par ce biais là c'est que les gens
qui regardent les vidéos ne s'abonne pas
forcément est en tout cas ce ne sont pas
les abonnés de la chaîne
donc au final qu'est ce qui marche et
comment fonctionne cette chaîne avec les
suggestions et avec les mots clefs et
avec les recherches
donc ce qui est vraiment très très
intéressant ce moment là c'est de se
focaliser sur la recherche c'est une
vraie stratégie
on va très bien que le mot clé légaux
stop motion a priori c'est quelque chose
qui marche plutôt pas mal donc là on est
effectivement sur une chaîne comme je
vous le disais à 72 unis l'abonné qui
fait celle qui est rolala 12 millions de
vu il ya deux mois c'est monstrueux ça
veut tout simplement dire que cette
vidéo en deux mois c'est clairement
référence et on a une deuxième scène cfk
film pareil un million neuf cent mille
vue et on a
280 mille abonnés pareil on va très bien
très clairement que les gens qui
arrivent là sont des gens qui sont
arrivés par les suggestions par la
recherche et non pas des abonnés de la
chaîne
et ça c'est super intéressant de se
rendre compte pas ce que ça veut dire à
l'excès qu'il faut vraiment que tu
travailles sur ton référencement et
c'est ça qui permettra de réussir
alors moi j'ai regarder ses vidéos et en
fin de compte ces vidéos elles vont en
point qui est extrêmement intéressant
c'est que elle ne parle pas c'est du
stop motion avec de la musique avec des
bruitages tous comprend uniquement avec
les bruitages et stop motion
ce qui fait qu'on est sur une cible
internationale on est sur une site qui
va toucher aussi bien les enfants qui
vont le regarder les aventures légaux
que les adultes qui adore les lego qui
ont une vraie nostalgie souffle le lego
c'est très clairement un truc avec une
cible qui est extrêmement large
alexis par contre fait d un contenu qui
est très très drôle mais qui par contre
est en français et qui sera plus dédiés
à des adultes ou des adolescents
ce qui fait que toute la cible enfants
elle est perdue alors à mon avis le
premier point améliorée quand on regarde
comment marcher la concurrence c'est
très clairement c'est ce soit en tout
cas c'est de passer sur un format
international plus de texte uniquement
d'humour uniquement de la suggestion et
un contenu vraiment qu'il va s'ouvrir
aux adultes comme aux enfants
à mon avis ça c'est une des clés du
succès ensuite ya deux choses qui sont
très très intéressante pour se rendre
compte si effectivement des mots clés
comme par exemple le mot clé légaux stop
motion c'est quelque chose qui marche
sur lequel il ya un volume de recherche
donc ça ne sert à rien de travailler des
mots clés qui ne marche pas la toute
première chose d'aller voir dans google
adwords c'est extrêmement intéressant et
on va se rendre compte rapidement s'il
ya un volume de recherche alors moi je
les taper tout à l'heure on va très bien
car recherches mensuelles on est entre
1000 et 10 mille c'est quand même plutôt
pas mal et après il ya toutes les
déclinaisons que vous allez pouvoir la
voir mais sur le volume global
c'est un million à 10 millions ce qui
fait que on est vraiment sur un marché
qui fonctionne
autre point intéressant c'est d'aller
voir dans google trends là très
clairement j'ai cherché de lego stop
motion dans google trends j'ai fait une
recherche en france sur les douze
derniers mois toutes les catégories et
sur le web entier on va filer on voit
très bien déjà qu'il y a
coût de recherche on va regarder que sur
youtube c'est pareil ça marche très très
bien et là je ne suis qu'en france on va
leur chercher à l'international dans
tous les pays et à mon avis ça va très
très bien marché c'est clair regardez la
course est juste dingue et là que sur
youtube sur le mot-clé légaux stop
motion c'est quelque chose qui marche
extrêmement bien et il faut travailler
ce mot clé il est extrêmement important
on s'embrasse sur youtube avec un petit
outil qui s'appelle tu le dis qui est
qui est payant si on souhaite l'utiliser
je vais taper la légaux stop motion
je recherche je vais avoir les volumes
de recherche sur une suggestion mots
clés des idées et c'est vraiment très
intéressant
qu'est ce que nous appelons tu me dis
qu'il y a un très gros volume de
recherche qu'il y a beaucoup de
concurrence et ça nous pose ensuite tout
plein de mots clés qui sont très
intéressants on va ré dans les
suggestions
on voit qu'il ya plein de choses à
développer les gosses notre motion star
wars et lego soit motion tutorial légaux
stop motion star wars battle il ya
énormément de choses à travailler autour
cet univers et on voit très clairement
qu'il faut axer sur le mot-clé légaux
stop motion
lorsque vous faites votre recherche lego
stop motion directement dans votre
résultat de youtube il faut que vous
fassiez aussi une recherche dans votre
navigateur dont vous êtes recherché et
vous tapez légaux stop motion
vous cherchez et là ça vous permettra de
voir si vous avez encore un moyen de
vous développer de vous positionner par
rapport à une stratégie de mots clés que
vous expliquer qu'en vont chercher ça
vous met en surbrillance les ghosts of
motion dans votre navigateur
on voit que le premier résultat qui
apparaît on voit que dans le titre les
ghosts of motion n'apparaît pas par
contre il apparaît dans la description
sur la deuxième vidéo il apparaît
directement dans le titre d'un
description troisième vidéo dont la
description n'est pas dans le titre
et ça on peut regarder un petit peu
partout et c'est très intéressant parce
que ça veut dire que si jamais
vous par exemple toi alexis tu vas
travailler et que tu mets dans toutes
les vidéos
au début les ghosts of motion et ensuite
tu a introduit le titre de ta vidéo et
que tu mets bien aussi en début de
descriptions tu leur mets bien dans tes
taxes ça veut dire que ta vidéo elle a
aussi une chance de se positionner par
rapport à cette stratégie là ce qu'il
faut vraiment c'est comprendre comment
sont référencés les concurrents et
comment toi aussi tu peux te référence
et il a très clairement on voit que
c'est un domaine qui est très
concurrentiel mais qu'on peut vraiment
optimisé je pense qu'il ya des places à
gagner
ensuite ce qui est intéressant c'est de
comparer le contenu là très clairement
on voit que le contenu c'est super bien
filmé la qualité de l'image est là c'est
très dynamique tous comprends moi je
vous conseille d'aller voir les toutes
les vidéos et les vidéos d'alexis depuis
les vidéos ci de lego stop motion pour
vraiment vous rendre compte c'est très
important a glissé de comparer la
concurrence et de voir comment avoir la
spécificité avoir ton humour et faire
toi ce que tu aimes mais comment être au
niveau est au même niveau et comment
tenu via mon avis tu as ta pas
grand-chose ya encore un petit détail
qui sont au niveau de la qualité de
l'image
alors moi j'ai identifié d'autres
problèmes sur sa chaîne alexis c'est à
dire quand on va regarder dans toutes
tes vidéos on voit qu'effectivement
propose des vidéos de stop motion pour
tous les goûts mais qui a aussi plein
d'autres choses et ça peut souvent créé
un petit peu le la confusion et bordel
pour les gens qui ne cherchent vraiment
que des vidéo en lego et en stop motion
en ce sens que la limite c'est pas
bloquant si les gens regardent une seule
vidéo et qu'après ils partent
regardez le dot dans les suggestions est
ce que tes vidéos pourront quand même
augmenté par contre s'il trouve que ton
contenu et bien qu'ils viennent regarder
la chaîne et qui veulent sa bonne et ça
peut bloquer qui peut bloquer ça peut
vraiment bloqué pour augmenter d
inscription et je pense que tout ça tu
es un peu en dehors de telle niche des
choses qui est très ciblé ton domaine tu
devrais à ce moment là de créer une
chaîne secondaire dans lequel toi tu va
développer ça à mon avis il faut
vraiment que tu es une seule chaîne en
cas tu te spécialisent sur des niches et
pas sur autre chose
maintenant on va regarder comment
améliorer le référencement des vidéos
parce que des vidéos sont quand même
très sympa mais on voit qu'il ya un vrai
problème en terme de
de référencement ça marche pas deux
minutes dans la vie d'un lego saison 2
épisode 6 le titre il est pas bon il est
pas bon du tout parce que tu ne peux pas
être trouvé avec ça le mot légaux qui
serait ton un des possibles
il est noyé au milieu du reste ce qu'il
faut qu'il fasse et que tu penses tu es
titre autrement tu devrais faire légaux
stop-motion tiré deux minutes dans la
vie dans lego saison 2 épisode 6 et au
quelqu'un ça permettra d'avoir une
requête de pour te référence et qui est
très très clair et très définie et qui
permettra de progresser la même chose
pour tes times si on regarde les tags
il ya il apparaît nulle part lego lego
ça ne lui apparaît pas légaux stop
motion ça n'apparaît pas il faut
vraiment que tu une base de mots clés
pour tâche elle regarde fait les
recherches se trouvera un lego
stop-motion lego batman lego star wars
faut construire à nantes et eyes au
moins légaux stop motion pour 7 permet
de référencer regarde ce que font les
autres
tu verras que ça ça paraît dans les tags
c'est indispensable pour référencer dans
ta description aussi on ne retrouve
nulle part
lego stop motion n'en parlons pas ce qui
fait que ce qui est très très important
on voit ça ce sont des points bloquants
pourtant référencement il faut que tu
mettes au début de ton titres lego stop
motion ou
le titre légaux que tu veux mais qui se
référent sera sur lequel il ya un volume
de recherche reprend ce que j'ai dit un
peu plus tôt il faut que tu fasses une
description un peu plus longue dans
lequel ces mots clés apparaissent
il faut qu'on les retrouve dans tes tag
est sûre ça permettra effectivement de
référence et que des vidéos grossistes
et qu'ensuite tu puisse convertir t'ai
vu en abonnés parce que là on voit très
bien par exemple sur cette vidéo il ya
un qui est un petit peu d'audience au
début et tout de suite ça tombait
ensuite ya quasiment rien ça veut dire
que ta vidéo ne se référencent pas tu
tes vidéos seront plutôt pas trop mal vu
59% de temps de vue c'est plutôt bien
tu as un ratio de l'aïe qui est très
très bien 48 like 0 dislike c'est super
non on voit qu'on voit que les gens qui
regardent même bien mais le problème de
ta chaîne c'est d'être découvert si on
regarde par exemple les autres on va
prendre celle qui a cartonné un qui a
des millions de vues eh bien tu vois que
les gosses est dans le titre
dans les pages on retrouve légaux spider
man spider man légaux spider man légaux
'spider-man' l'ecobank robbery enfin tu
retrouves tous ces mots clés qui font de
la vidéo pourra se référencer tu le
retrouves probablement dans la
description légaux spider man peinture
trouve les mots clés et ce qui fait que
cette vidéo il est référent sable mais
si tu regarde l'historique tu vas qu'au
début il ya un peu de vue et ensuite il
y en a d'autres qui arrivent
régulièrement et ça ça vient du fait que
la vidéo elle se référencent entre pas
qui pourrait être amélioré c'est le nom
tasha d'alexis méliz s'étend dans sa
fonction il n'y a pas de problème par
contre on pourrait rajouter une petite
partie où l'art modifier ton qui
permettrait d'avoir une meilleure
compréhension de quoi pas ta chaine
typiquement là tu pourrais rajouter
alexis maëlys légaux stop motion stop
motion
ce qui permettrait effectivement
quelqu'un qui arrive de savoir tout de
suite de quoi on parle il ya aussi la
bannière qui peut être revu pour mieux
comprendre effectivement de quoi parle t
elle donner un rendez vous dire dans
quel jour je vous fais une prochaine
vidéo venant juste d'avoir une petite
animation qui permet effectivement de
mettre en scène et de comprendre que tu
raconte une histoire
le storytelling c'est ce qui est plus
important sur youtube ce qui peut être
intéressant pour trouver des idées de
vidéos à faire et pour référencer parce
que tu aurais ference et sur l'ego stop
motion c'est bien mais il ya plein
d'autres cas qui peuvent être très
intéressantes
moi ce que je te conseille c'est dans ta
part de recherche sur youtube c'est de
taper légaux et ensuite ça va proposer
lego stop-motion français légaux stop
motion star wars lego star wars lego
city lego batman et même si tu continues
à taper par exemple lego batman lego
batman stop motion
lego batman empressé pour le film mais
ça permettra effectivement de trouver
plein de requêtes de recherche sur
lesquels toi tu peux faire des vidéos
alors après tu fais pareil tu va
regarder directement
toi et pour vous aussi ce sur vos idées
de vidéos regardées sur google adwords
vallée sur google trends d'avoir un
petit peu s'il ya du volume de recherche
s'il ya une actualité si ça intéresse
les gens en ce moment et ça permettra
effectivement à cette vidéo d'être
référencés et à la chaîne de croître
alors si on regarde les analytics de la
chaîne par exemple on va regarder on va
comparer avec laniel on a en rouge
le nombre d'abonnés sur les 28 derniers
sont les 30 derniers jours d'alexis y en
a un par jour 0,1 et même eu des
négatifs qui sont des abonnés c'est ça
reste compliqué et si on compare si on
regarde depuis le début le nom d'abonnés
il a coup la progression de la de la
courbe de croissance
on voit très bien qu'on est sur un
groupe qui est très très très linéaire
avec quasiment pas d'abonnés depuis 2013
depuis le lancement de la chaîne en
quatre ans il s'est pas passé grand
chose on compare avec la mienne
moi j'ai vraiment travaillé depuis le
mois de janvier la chaîne est depuis
janvier
c'est parti il ya une progression tous
les mois et c'est cet type de courbe
qu'il faut alors il ya des plateaux il
est au moins symboliquement au sein des
100 mais c'est très clairement ce genre
de coupe qu'il faut avoir sur sa chaîne
et en appliquant cette méthode de
référencement de compréhension d'un
analyse de la concurrence
on va progresser le problème d'alexis ce
n'est pas la qualité du contenu ce n'est
pas la création ce ne sont pas les idées
c'est le problème de stratégie de
référencement
cette problématique alexis n'est pas le
seul à la rencontre et c'est bien pour
ça que j'ai fait une vidéo pouvoir un
petit peu comparé avec vous aussi avec
vos problèmes voir quels sont les
problèmes comment les analyser comment
progresser voire les voies
d'amélioration et essayer de comprendre
un petit peu bien qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour que sa chaîne réussisse
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura utile
si c'est le cas je vous invite à laisser
un joli pouces bleus vers le haut à vous
abonner parce qu'on aura de plus en plus
de vidéos sur les stratégies youtube et
pour vous aider à faire évoluer les
faire grandir votre chaîne à avoir plus
de vue et à les convertir en abonnés
haute à moi je vous dis merci
une mais yvonne commentaires dites moi
ce que vous en avez pensé et puis
surtout par les mots de votre chaîne des
puys connaissez un petit peu trop
regarder s'il ya des clés 1 qui peuvent
être tout de suite actionnable pour
réussir sur youtube merci à vous à très
bientôt
et d'ici là portez vous bien ciao
[Musique]